lancée au loire et un les habitants du
loiret achevé le grand mémorial du
loiret pour ce 11 novembre 2019 puisque
les archives départementales avaient
décidé de leur proposer ce travail à eux
plutôt qu'à une entreprise commerciale
c'est une opération dite d'annotations
collaborative c'est à dire qu'on permet
aux internautes particulièrement
internautes loire est un qui ont des
ancêtres loire et un de venir enrichir
le contenu qu'on la met à disposition la
première étape de ce travail a donc été
la numérisation des 150000 livret
militaire des loire est un qui furent
engagés dans cette immense tragédie qui
marqua le début du 20e siècle puis de
faire appel aux loire et un du 21e
siècle
nous ce qu'on a proposé aux internautes
c'est que à partir des images qu'on a
numérisé ils puissent aller a ajouté les
informations qu'ils lisaient dans la
fiche
non ça demande un peu quelques
compétences pour arriver à lire les
documents mais assez vite ils se sont
pris au jeu et ils sont allés regarder
toutes les fiches matricule qu'on avait
mis en ligne pour ajouter le nom et
prénom la date de naissance le lieu de
naissance le lieu de résidence mais
aussi la profession le degré
d'instruction qui sont des éléments
extrêmement intéressant ensuite quand on
veut faire de l'histoire
l'enfer que vécurent ses hommes nul ne
l'a mieux raconter que l'immense
écrivain que fut maurice genevoix dans
son livre ceux de 14
maurice genevoix blessé sur la crête des
efforts en 1915 était loire et 1 est
donc bien lancée registres matricules on
trouve par exemple le la fiche de
maurice genevoix et donc on en voit dans
ce registre
l'ensemble de ces affectations
pendant son ca conscription ses
blessures ses citations
dans différents ordres ainsi que son
état civil ou encore des détails
physiques puisqu'on à cette époque là on
mettait systématiquement la couleur des
yeux des cheveux etc
aux archives départementales du loiret
il s'agit donc de fournir aux historiens
davantage de matière mais aussi de
transmettre la mémoire de ces hommes des
tranchées des classes y travaillent
notamment s'exerçant écrire des lettres
à la façon de ce 2 14